he's back that's right I'm back and uh
you know I have a history of debunking
superhero myths on this channel and uh
while I'm in town this week I was
racking my brain trying to think of one
for Spider-Man apparently Nico says he
has one I'm not sure what it is but
hopefully it's like web slinging or
something yeah yo what's up Jake yeah
okay so I have this I had a Spider-Man
test all right I think only Spider-Man
can pull this one off okay all right
right here
[Music]
you know you gotta have spidey-like
reflexes to be able to catch all the
food on tray and they figured you know
what let's prove that Toby Maguire has
what it takes to be Spider-Man let's do
it for real and it took them 16 hours in
156 tries to get it right what this is
real I always thought this was a CG shot
yeah this is real right here if you say
that this is doable let's just go back a
little bit and see actually how they did
this like the first thing that stands
out to me is there's like a bunch of
really good insert shots that like set
everything up and make it feel like
you're watching something really
complicated it's just good
cinematography but the actual stunt here
we got the tray dropping and just
fingers so he has like a sticky
substance on his hand and the Apple
Falls in this apple sticky too you can
see that oh yeah the milk carton's
sticky and the bowl is sticky stuff on
it so we cut all of it and get this
perfect camera move also pushes in don't
miss the focus and don't don't forget
the line wow great reflexes took them
156 tries to get that and I can see why
it's like you're juggling basically I
thought we were going to be web slinging
or something obviously web slinging
requires ropes wires or CGI this though
performed by human performed by human
I've done Batman we all remember I've
got Superman I walked around in the
office for 10 minutes no one knew it was
me yeah you did it again Jake and now
Spider-Man I'm going for it do you think
Peter would like let me be Spider-Man in
his next like Spiderman shorts yeah if
we package up this clip we sent it to
Peter we can use reaction at the end and
see if he would kind of see it oh yes
this is gonna be my way to convince him
that I can play Spider-Man yeah here's
the thing Peter is not gonna give a crap
if you take more takes in Sam Remy and
toading guard it's like whatever then
any chump can do it right we gotta be
better totally 156 tries let's do it
less yeah I think we can do it yes okay
I was hoping for one of these
okay uh well we've gotten everything
together we got the bread milk cartons
the apples the jello and the trays I've
even got my blue shirt on to move more
like Toby in the scene uh but I think
that's it am I forgetting anything
you're a co-star oh yes um so we need a
Mary Jane so naturally uh as my co-star
I thought I'd call on Jordan
oh
do you need me
you know what it's fine come on heck
yeah come on baby hey what are we doing
all right so
um I'm throwing you off a little bit I
can feel like you're not I just wasn't
expecting this yeah I like to just hang
around Jordan hoping that she'll
eventually sub me in so but hey at least
you got the red hair that that's not
correlated to this that just happens all
right so here's what we're gonna do um
we're gonna set everything up we're
gonna start dropping items at the
beginning of every take you're just
gonna rise up with me rise up with you
yeah there's one very very important
part of this though yeah if either of us
forgets our line
the line is as important as every single
item that lands on that trip wow great
reflexes
thanks no problem wow great reflexes
thanks no problem
I'm a nurse my heart so what we're gonna
do first we're gonna drop one item at a
time on the tray as practice to get a
feel for the weight and the placement
before we actually start doing the full
takes
uh we just noticed that when the
double-sided tape touches the Gaff tape
it's way more sticky so I'm covering
this whole tray in Gaff tape do you
think that they might have done this on
Spiderman oh yeah they would have used
every trick in the book all right who's
doing Apple
matte Milkman Milkman sandwich Jello
cameraman and Sam Remy
Apple milk sandwich Jello Apple milk
sandwich Joe Apple milk sandwich gel
rehearsals up all right guys let's see
what happens all right three two one
Trey Apple milk sandwich
[Applause]
the time is upon us the fabled first
take it's gonna happen first take first
try this is when magic can happen three
two one
wow thanks that was really cool I think
we're gonna get like 30. three two one
thank you
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
wow wow great reflexes thanks be honest
how's my feminine energy I want to be
there for Jake you're just a huge dude I
think that's the issue
three two one
oh you guys are so close
everything that's great let's get one of
our safeties
that was basically it it's the jello
can't spill nothing it's always one
thing oh [ __ ] and I don't know if it's
like a space issue on the tray
foreign
hey guys it's me Spider-Man here on the
set of a big Hollywood movie and I know
Jake is in the studio right now trying
to take my job and whatnot but there's
one tool of the trade that I don't think
he knows about and that is the raycon
everyday earbud courtesy of today's
sponsor raycon see the best thing about
raycon everyday earbuds is that they
have optimized gel tips to give you the
perfect in-ear fit meaning that if
you're web slinging or you're in an
action scene these will not budge out of
your ears and they're gonna be actually
comfortable in your ear all day long in
addition to that raycons have over eight
hours of play time and a 32 hour battery
life and they come in a convenient
rechargeable carrying case that I just
web sling to my side I mean I put them
in my pockets but my suit doesn't have
any pockets in addition to that raycons
are priced just right meaning that
you're going to get great quality and a
great deal so if you're interested in
getting a pair of raycons for yourself
and getting 15 off just click the link
in the description below or go to
byraycon.com Corridor crew that's 15 off
by going to buy raycon.com Corridor crew
or just click the link in the
description below
oh hey I think they're calling me back
to sister we're on a takeover
so hopefully we'll get we'll get this
take and uh I won't lose my job to Jake
I I think you know he's probably he's
got a good chance so anyways good luck
to him and uh
I'm out of here whoa
I'm feeling good about this we're on to
take 24 and uh We've Come very close a
few times so we just gotta keep at it ah
this is gonna be the one three two one
wow great reflexes damn you're jealous
what
that I mean Jordan yeah
if you were saying Remy would you accept
that here's a reality you guys did it
congratulations you did it in 27 tries
hey
[Applause]
would that be
in the
gym don't do better three two one
oh
three two one
three two one
great reflexes
thanks no problem
[Applause]
33 tanks
33 has been my lucky number for my whole
life coincidence
foreign
literally a little bit of speed
remapping to match the original I think
we did it I think we did I think we did
a darn good job Bravo seriously Peter's
gonna put me in his spider his next he
hasn't made a choice he doesn't have a
choice now you really don't understand
how hard it is until you actually start
doing it you know it's like it's so much
coordination just for one quick shot
when the jello landed perfect I blanked
on my line for just a second I like
black down right no
and that came to me just muscle memory
dude yes amazing amazing
this catch stunt is nothing without the
context of the scene that it's in so we
went out of our way to actually shoot
frame for frame shot for shot the exact
scene that surrounds this shot so that
when he hits that tray when that every
item lands on it it means something hey
you have blue eyes I
guess is
you get contacts
I felt something stirring thoughts of a
constitution put a baby in me I want to
give birth to a nation
I didn't think that I wanted this role
but
not watching him I should have done it
and he's such a diva don't look at me
hey
everybody carrot makeup
I I consider myself quite a Spider-Man
snob and I heard there's something
Spider-Man related going on so so what's
going on we sat out with a mission to
impress you by doing a Spider-Man shot
that only Spider-Man can do ourselves
and convince you that you need to cast
me as the next Spider-Man in your next
Spider-Man I mean usually there's like a
long casting process and talking with
Executives and everything like that the
bar is the bar is high but if you wow me
with this shot you will be the next
Spider-Man in my movie not in the
official but look at the unofficial
beer just just you know this is another
person here that also thinks they have
what it takes to be
Spider-Man's love interest who who is
the new Mary Jane it's very rare that as
an actor you find a role you feel you
were born to play and I feel like I
finally found that role I can just see
you falling into Jake's arms and I love
it when you see my hairline you'll fall
in love as well I can't wait he's like
crying almost that's right Apple milk
kind of uncomfortable here we go
oh my God it's perfect oh my God
what's up
[Applause]
great reflexes
thanks
you have blue eyes
I didn't notice about your glasses did
you just get contacts
okay
that's amazing position is like
perfectly matched how did you guys like
get the perfect focal length and the
lighting and everything I just rewatched
that scene so many times it's incredible
this is you Jake you got the role
Jake hasn't been this happy since
catching a bunch of food on a lunch
trade yesterday
exactly how many days did it take took
Sam made me 156. yeah how many takes you
think it took us 300. divide that by 10.
35
McGuire's got nothing on you yeah Toby
McGuire
you're out of here
I see you in a new light after watching
this video I really like you in that wig
and I think you for sure should be the
Damsel in Distress in this new
Spider-Man video I mean it thank you so
much
look everyone's going crazy they're all
so happy I'm gonna swallow my pride
from one actress to another good job
thank you
why are you shaking my hand like that
I'm doing it gently don't make it weird
so three videos into this whole like
Cinema debunk idea and I apparently
still am doubting Jake and it's probably
time that I change my ways you really
got what it takes to be a star man
thanks man I really you know keep that
doubt because I thrive on that doubt
okay without that doubt I don't know if
I'd be motivated to even try these
things well you know what I really don't
think you have what it takes to be a
star but if you subscribe maybe in
future videos you can see if Jake has
what it takes to at least impress me
once more what other movie myths do you
guys want to see us take on I mean we've
done Batman Spider-Man Superman there's
got to be more Ant-Man and you'd be
really tiny let us know in the comments
yeah we're out of ideas
[Music]
the donkey's coming come on chunky
chunky this way step this way and we got
a freaking donkey and a baby a child
with us I have a bad feeling about this
all right well shall we we shall clunk
The Miner hits the lever
and the elevator starts lowering and
half hour passes nothing happens
another half hour passes
everyone rolls reception checks 23.
I eat oh wow eight the elevator starts
to become unsteady
if I look down the elevator shop can I
see the bottom you look down I actually
start to see a little bit of light
coming up it's very distant probably
about 15 minutes out from hitting the
bottom if you look up and the shaft it's
tight if it's rock walls there's a
couple lanterns here and there as
they're passing by it's calm it's quiet
other than it's occasional
against the grow
I need to take that amulet off for a
second you can keep it and you take it
off for a second
oh excuse me watch What's Happening Here
I'm just gonna be direct just put it out
there
I think you got a worm in your head
are you kidding me uh no of course so we
can revolve all this really easily it's
particularly off for a second
Timothy here is just gonna see if you
can detect it if you can feel the forces
you'll be fine if you have in your head
we have multiple ways to take it out
there's nothing wrong with me at all I
swear
fantastic I feel like I'm 23. Theo you
need to do this it's not a request
19 on persuasion Theo buddy this is for
the good of the party right now where am
I what are you talking about a person he
freezes and locks up all right I go up
and I take off his amulets are as right
as he reach the amulet was real loud
just go straight over the top of the
Elevator Shaft and you see the worm just
go
and it just like cleanly cuts through
the cables cut through the cables that
are holding the elevator up as in the
elevators now and then we are now in
free fall
[Music]